often considered the dumbest person in
DC that would be Biden's Chief of Staff
Ron Clane he's now praising Joe Biden
his hard work and his steady leadership
compared to Donald Trump's take a listen
I just think Donald Trump created an
expectation of a president creating a
storm every single day
I don't think it was good for the
country I don't think the voters wanted
it and I think 81 million of them showed
up
last in 2020 and said they wanted a
different kind of president
and that's who Joe Biden is he comes
into the Oval Office every morning he's
serious about his work he's serious
about the change he's trying to bring to
this country
all right Ron are you serious really
because every time Joe opens his mouth
it is a complete Adam Schiff Show here's
a friendly reminder
[Music]
the um
[Music]
with the nature
not
when
the political coverage of the
[Music]
that look
um
some of the political
players and some of the
let me ask you rhetorical question
no anyway Ron do you or anybody else at
the White House do you ever feel bad
putting Joe in that position every day
because you're living in an alternate
reality now Biden's entire presidency
has been a horror show both at home and
abroad and by the way Joe's well it
definitely uh does not go to the office
or the Oval Office every morning as you
claim not even close so far Joe Biden
has spent 150 whopping days on vacation
in Delaware and this weekend he's headed
back to the beach in Delaware after a
lengthy vacation at the Beach in South
Carolina where he's going to build a
wall to secure his premises Joe Biden is
not serious about his work because he's
not mentally capable of being serious
about work he can't even put his own
jacket on like a functioning adult but
in the Democratic party it just simply
doesn't matter Democrats don't really
care about Biden's mental decline his
cognitive decline or or the disaster in
Afghan Afghanistan now a little over a
year ago they don't seem to care about
inflation high gas prices the recession
they don't seem to care about any of it
they don't even care that Joe's son zero
experience Hunter appears to have sold
access to the highest levels of the U.S
federal government all to make millions
and millions and millions from China
Russia Ukraine and many other countries
that don't particularly like the United
States but Democrats claim to Revere our
institutions no they don't Revere our
institutions they only care about
political power raw political power but
don't take my word for it just listen to
a popular liberal podcast host his name
is Sam Harris he just says what others
think
at Trump University as a story is worse
than anything that could be in in Hunter
Biden's laptop in my view right now
that's not that doesn't answer the
people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the New York post's twitter account
like that that's just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to Donald Trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but I
think it was warranted
now it's all a means to an end there is
no intellectual honesty or Fidelity to
the truth in the Democratic party of
today they will lie they will cheat they
will steal their way to the top if
that's what it takes to gain power and
they will do it together with one United
voice take a look at the so-called
inflation reduction act or I call it the
tax the poor the middle class and people
on fixed income act all it is is one
giant 500 billion dollar farce and it
doesn't even attempt to reduce inflation
it'll increase inflation it increases
taxes on the poor middle class people on
fixed incomes it drives up everybody's
energy costs at a time when gas is still
near a record high it hires 85 or to 87
000 new IRS agents to audit small
businesses bigger than three agencies of
the federal government combined but
guess what both the Americans will now
be able to enjoy a big tax credit now if
they have a buyer and expensive new
electric vehicle or an EV as they like
to call them every single Democrat in
the Senate voted in favor of this bill
they don't care if Americans get hurt
they just want a political win their
green climate religious cult trumps
everything now these same Democrats are
painting Republican Senate candidates
running an upcoming elections and
midterms as cruel and out of touch well
apparently Senator Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell is content to
leave them out to dry and fend for
themselves listen to these comments very
encouraging
there's a probably a greater likelihood
the house flips than the center
Senate races are just different they're
Statewide
candidate quality has a lot to do with
the outcome
candidate quality you mean like in
Pennsylvania the Democratic Senate
candidate a devout socialist style in
the in the vein of let's see oh Bernie
Sanders who he endorsed over Joe Biden a
guy that literally can't put two
sentences together himself he's only
been 11 minutes on the campaign Trail a
guy that wants to legalize heroin and
have areas where people can shoot up in
public and I hope fetterman gets better
health-wise but it's just a simple fact
he's to the left of Bernie Sanders and
yet you don't hear Chuckie Schumer
complaining about candidate quality in
Pennsylvania
how about you get out there Mitch and
fight for your team uh what's your
agenda Mitch would you rather just sit
by and watch helplessly as Democrats lie
to your face pass another 500 billion
dollar green energy boondoggle next year
or is it maybe Mitch McConnell hates
Donald Trump so much that he would
probably rather see Trump endorse
candidates lose because he thinks that
might hurt Donald Trump his time as a
leader needs to come to an end now if
Republicans fail to take the majority we
will get even more taxes we'll get more
audits we will get more inflation we
will get more socialism we will get more
green New Deal more mass illegal
immigration that means more fentanyl
more heroin more crime more chaos more
con Carnage and a far left deep state
bureaucracy left totally completely
unchecked this is a critical inflection
point for this country a pivotal moment
a Tipping Point if Mitch doesn't really
want to help lead his party Mitch step
aside we'll find somebody who can lead
and Champion the candidates that are in
these races hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else